hello hey there my name is Dan Galpin
and this is cocaine and we're here for
another episode of the Friday games
review also producing for us is Ian
Lewis that's Ian knee Lewis sorry about
that yeah I had it legally changed my
wife is gonna kill you that's if she's
watching right my wife always watches
this show exactly so how about a beer I
don't think we're gonna get one to dan I
was I always want a beer I was just in
Germany last week nice continue is that
how you got tan you don't usually that's
not that's not how to happen actually it
was very warm in Germany today's beer is
the widmer brothers Imperial Stout
raspberry Imperial Stout we've been on
kind of a widmer brothers kick here
because we used to think of them as just
a bland corporate you know like Samuel
Adams alike and lately they've been
doing some really cool experimental
beers so we're having the raspberry
Russian Imperial Stout it's a really
strong beer it's got just a hint of
raspberries in it we'll see how these
guys can tolerate it if we have to carry
one of them out during the show I'll
just go ahead and step in back to you
Dan good to know you're here for us ok
so today I'm wearing the hard hat as
we're looking at brain and puzzle games
I don't know why that really actually
makes any sense but we got an excited
games for you on some of them we really
really love this week I just wanted to
say that there's some that we played
more than my play of some of these other
games these are really addicting puzzler
so warning to anyone out there if you
actually has a rarely in these games be
expect expect to have to lose a lot of
free time and we also have some games
that I think have some interesting
technical issues so we'll try to talk
through those as well as the ones we
really really liked and as always these
games were nominated by you out there in
the audience on our moderator page so
continue to nominate
and we will continue to look at them
yeah for sure any more ways to make me
pass my commute from san francisco de
it's about view so exactly exactly we're
here to help fill in that gap in those
in those long hours so I want which game
you want look at first I think I think
that so I I have them in this order I
don't this is this make sense oh yeah we
can start with all the word games first
so all right so we're going to start off
with word push and so this is this is
going to be a portrait game and once it
actually lived there we are excellent
it's going to be it's fun to like we're
actually looking at a screen and has it
back or a tier so it's gonna it's a
little tricky to look at so let's check
it yeah so Cohen I both play this game
quite a lot and some basic things that
that it gets wrong and right so one of
things that gets wrong is that's what
happens if you could hit the back key
right the game yeah let me just say
that's a little annoying because I
always like have I always accidentally
hit the back heat Becky all the time
it's actually a pretty obnoxious top of
the times and every time I try to like
solve it I'm like wait no no progress
saved okay yeah so so it immediately
loses all progress immediately exits the
game and this is actually the default
behavior of an Android activity but
unfortunately when you have a game
you're having multiple different
interstitials that are going on we have
a title screen we have a level select
screen time we have the game itself just
exiting doesn't really help and also
losing all state could be very very
frustrating if you're in the middle of
one of these levels and here is an
example word push level and it's
actually the game is super super clever
one thing it's also interesting about
this game for me is that there is
a large sense of complete randomness to
the game as is how close these blocks
are to each other so the goal in this
particular level by the way is to build
one word using the blue blocks and they
must be used to actually it's using the
orange blocks and so the blue blocks
actually gives you additional monta but
to complete a level you actually need to
hit get make a word with the orange box
icic okay in that case and you used it
to keep anyway the point is if you use
the blue blocks they actually have to be
used together and and so that's that it
does make things kind of turkey so okay
so you can see I played this game a lot
um clearly today okay all our word games
are almost the same to us at this point
so yeah so and you can actually and you
can move the other letters out of the
way in different directions by selecting
top left right or bottom yeah and it has
a nice little animation one of things
that's a little bit unclear is it if you
don't want the the video how to play
intro that is built into the game and
some of these things may elude you in
the in terms of the controls and it
still got a little bit confusing as to
what top left right and bottom mean in
terms of push direction I think it's one
of the things that could be made a lot
clearer in the game itself perhaps a
direction indicator I think right yeah
you know Shaw and arrow on the board or
something showing you the way the
letters are going to move and we said
you're actually to care it's really what
happens when you move things out of the
way so now we are at top direction right
and sea kraits oh yeah English it's okay
i know i put Dame I didn't like the age
okay let's let's try tan okay you see
now top moves the letters from the top
down oh yeah right okay that's and
that's that's again it's not necessarily
doesn't mean the lid so that that's how
that's how this explains here so we
explains we move to the right here it's
going to move letters in from the right
that's that's just one and then it's
going to lift stuff from the bottom so
yeah once you figured out and a lot of
it is is I actually didn't even know
that existed until level five or six and
so or at least really made full
attention of that so I think a lot of it
is
I mean if your user like me who ignores
YouTube videos on the google play market
you may want to make that more clear
when you start setting up the game and
introducing a game to your users ya na
de tutorial is nicely integrated into
the game the sense that the YouTube
video is a link from the name from the
main page of the game here and so the
good news at least if you're gotta look
at the camera dude I'm offering any
place I have I unfortunately have to
either look at one or the other I can't
operate this game in in back this mode
I'm supposed to be so yeah the problem
is also moving this is challenging all
right so but anyways when you're
operating when you're actually operating
the the game you can move you can go
back using the into the game by actually
hitting the home key in going back ooh
that's not fortunate I was going to try
to demonstrate something else um
pennyways the real key thing here is
just navigating within the game goes on
back button that just needs to be fixes
a lot of other subtle details I think
it'd be cleaned up to make the game just
that much better the YouTube video it
says YouTube gameplay demo here is
actually what there's a lake which I
really tell you by the way you really
should watch this to figure that game so
that's but that's word push now I wanted
to talk about before we get into our
next word game one of the things that
was nominated was 50 lakhs which is the
first game done by this developer okay
and this is another game that does a
whole bunch of things that are a little
bit unfortunate and but there are a lot
of kind of newbie Android experience
things and so what's nice about the game
is it has really really wonderfully
rendered tiles right and and for which
the developer actually went and proposed
a the fantastic open-source rendering
package to use but the problem with this
game is actually a problem of saved
state so I'll show you I'll show you the
most the most obvious problem here so
you go here you go here i'm going to
select this tile this tiles said it's
only available in 4 by 4 and i can
select would
marble or plastic for the backgrounds
and I hit play and now now there's a
couple of problems we get into the
screen here one is that hitting the back
he actually accepts the games is the
game once again so that's that's
problematic I'm going to go back now
it's nice thing you see it's actually
remember the tile that I said that I use
but you notice that it didn't actually
remove these other ones again so here's
the problem if I go back to this screen
I can now select six by six tiles here
and if I actually hit play you end up
with that yeah so there were a lot of
just sort of bugs the other problem is
that is that this key here looks like
restart in action which is what be
really nicely does that but actually
what is it also takes you back to the
main menu another other problems this
game has when we go back to the main
menu here get to a non corrupt looking
screen is that this this particular view
here sort of feels like an intro to the
game right but in fact it is all in the
same activity and because of that hangs
back you know get out of both the other
things the game does though which is
pretty really pretty unusual is if you
actually hit and go back to you know the
home screen and then try to go back into
the game you'll see that the game
actually has now changed its state right
and so any like any any exit from the
game at all but however it's interrupted
read changes the state so this is
something you should know it's
definitely worth fixing so first of all
we have an on-screen indicator that sort
of does what a back you would do but
actually doesn't and then we have this
kind of immediate kill behavior I'm Brad
a key and one other thing at least for
me it's just it actually took me forever
to figure out how to actually move the
tiles because then you know in games
like this you're always used to like
guess your base stuff whereas like oh
I'm got to slide the tile well
apparently instead of you can't really
slide the tile you actually need to
press the actually side like just
basically pushed aside and put it in the
direction of moves it's kind of weird
because it took me a while to figure
that out but definitely like making
making sure that your users in kind of
know how to at least understanding how
the game is based and if they play these
games before make sure whatever
guesstures are you I
that you put in make sure it matches
well this would be a great a great time
to use the gesture detector that's built
into the android framework you can
actually detect that that that kind a
kind of that that kind of gesture which
was would be a paging gesture we
actually call it a guy the name of
anyways you can actually detect this
this kind of sliding gesture we want to
slide the entire row the other thing
that it would that I think would really
help this game at it's actually a way of
demonstrating what the solution is hang
on you guys sorry I I just need to break
in for one second engineer Daniel asked
what game are you reviewing now mmm that
is that is that is a good question we
are that we are actually looking at 15
puzzle s hey wait a second I thought we
looked at this and it was kind of like a
lot more awesome-looking what happened I
switched the tile to plastic mode mode
oh so we can select I like the wood
better yeah wood looks really cool yeah
except except for one thing and it's
like youth of comics and thank you's a
guy Sam oh and by the way co not not
over here right I'm underneath you
you're underneath me yeah what's up all
right whatever actually can use a story
right all right what's up with comic
sans yeah comic sans hahaha was it was a
large presence can you you know what's
gonna happen though now that we've
mentioned Comic Sans is a ton of people
are gonna email us and say hey that's
not Comic Sans that's such-and-such
which happens to be a typeface that
looks just like comic sans you know what
not fooling anybody so um so yeah so
definitely some gestures i also think
knowing where the solution is it's not
clear that the numbers actually should
be going across or they should be going
up and down and at whether one should be
you know where one should be right i
think i think that would also be very
very useful to actually show the
solution but that's kind of that's kind
of a minor knit day i think most people
understand what whether it's good boy to
understand what a number puzzle is or at
least is that you know sometimes you do
want to solve 123456 and beyond both
solutions are actually acceptable i'm
after it's true I never actually got my
point
she's solving this but yeah I'm not a
huge fan of the number puzzle and never
puzzled but a really great first effort
and on and you get a beautifully
rendered tiles and and again just some
things to think about the biggest one I
think really is is it is a state and
these controls here in order to disable
them when you're actually going back
here you need to actually go through and
run through that same disable logic
because you really don't want users to
get to this screen action yeah and also
be nice to see a splash screen of what
I'm playing too but maybe that's another
thing i hate this flash bang but i do
think it'd be nice if it were if it
worked but it is no particular reason
why a game like this needs to go
fullscreen right and i would much rather
see the time and my notifications and
all that kind of thing when i'm playing
a game that doesn't need to be
completely immersive ok actually does
this game actually is a game that um is
damaged by mar sivadier and benefit
benefiting by it i could see that no no
alright cool next game next game mm-hmm
all right where we did nice a little bit
about that your kitchen I this game
actually I had a lot of compatibility
problems with houses a device where drug
Allah and you can probably see it's kind
of not wanting to turn on his trans on
his transformer but yeah one of the
things that's interesting about this
game is it actually goes it immediately
creates a profile account yeah using my
email yeah using your thanks everyone
for asking no no it doesn't it it is
plugged in it's plugged in its flashing
it's flashing so so this is word Ruggles
we should change 15 puzzle accent and go
to work right raggle and and work so
we're having gonna have a really hard
time actually showing you any gameplay
here on this device sorry everyone it is
it just we're not trying to give you a
seizures it doesn't promise you with it
with the transformer of try try jiggling
the cable on the Nexus 7 but let's
switch the camera yeah you can switch
the cameras you can see with actually
doing here
produced any last did you jiggle it and
the answer is yes Cena like we're not
kidding this happening whether or not
hdmi is on but ok so see ya again I
think you might want to move your head a
little bit too oh yeah yeah yeah you can
see it doesn't get that that's what's
going on here so unfortunately we can't
really look at the gameplay this but
I'll let Co talk about it what why don't
you go ahead and just uh the Nexus
stepping up there and I think seems
we're all right next seven why should I
turn okay mm-hmm right here yeah we say
they're here we are Nexus 7 okay all
right so seven cam so that's you know to
me I don't know where that's a layout
issue because I haven't tried it none
other tablet devices over the Nexus 7 it
could be but let's do I need to like
read no no I'll figure it out yeah I
mean a lot of it it's kind of like a
bottle game so you just turned from the
four-by-four set you need to swipe as
many words as you possibly can which is
pretty cool I mean it's all this but
it's a real-time game should everyone
else that's the kind of quotes very very
similar to two word hero which you look
at on the show I like actually looks
really nice I you don't the only thing I
would say about it is is that it it does
feel a little bit a little bit borrowed
from another platform learned in terms
of look with all of the roundedness and
all of the excessive use of gradients
and stuff like that by the way viewers
at home would you not all agree that
Dan's hair is rich and luxurious almost
Rockstar like in its silky splendor he
kind of jealous a lot of volume Oh shed
that much volume right so also oh thank
god dan isn't leaning slightly to his
left because then his head would be
totally out of shot and it would ruin it
for the rest of us Thank You Ian I
always always good to have that that's
why Ian's producing
yeah so that he can drink more and make
comments like rat so um here be so
so yeah so uh so basically it's now
we're actually competing against the
entire world and and there's there's
lots of us a lot of system so the game
is fun i love i love this kind of random
competition a kind of game i was a
really huge fan of war hero I know
basically I want to see them do some
nice tablet lay outside be very very
cool to see the words that you're
actually guessing in larger form sorry
untied side by side with a game board if
you're on a tablet layout and you know
again there's just a lot more that can
be done here people need to see but it
there you go no its total ride right
thanks thanks thanks to my makeover
expert over there on the right so so
anyways I don't know much more we've
really much more to say about this
because it is a real-time game this is
actually one of those really really is
actually a good good game for actually
putting up a dialogue very very rare
that I would actually suggest putting up
a dialogue right this but this is real
time so closing so actually exiting the
game just kind of ruin your ability to
play that particular round so it makes
sense and it does take you back here to
the level screen and then that takes you
out so that's all that's all good
navigation wouldn't we the rest the
games will actually work on the
transformer prime yes I did promise
sorry yeah but after that particular
game we did actually have to go through
some additional effort to get to work
and again you know being able to test on
one on one tablet is always a good thing
it's kind of unusual because it looks
like that game is using the framework so
it's kind of a strange thing to start
game that's having trouble that is a
good framework
alright we are going we're going in in
in in order here so the next game is
stackable okay so such camps is somewhat
this one actually works so exactly we
switch keys and we're now in a game and
that ball goal is to make the ball sack
to match the shadows easy right at the
bottom of the level it's kind of like
reverse Tetris so that the object is is
to stack the balls as many as you can
without actually having three balls
connecting at any time and so you're
supposed to keep stacking until you run
out of balls this is going to be really
unfun on my tablet cuz it does make it
take advantage of accelerant right so
usually when I rotate this thing will
lose HDMI will turn really careful here
Ian likes to point out how dorky this
looks when I'm actually using the
keyboard with an accelerometer gained it
really does but on the other hand yeah I
tend to to not lose HDMI quite often you
do have to push the tap the screen to
release the balls and so part of the
challenge is actually an arcade live
challenge and part of it and it's kind
of unfortunately random also so you see
if I those three balls touch they get
destroyed right since the balls come in
apparently random colors the challenge
is also somewhat random which is a
little unfortunate well the one the one
big thing I actually have probably is I
never know when I'm actually done and so
because it says just keep going until
there's no more balls but it'd be nice
for the ball counter to be the reverse
count not how many balls I have going
down the thing and it's also pretty slow
too I mean for an arcade game that's
kind of like all about falling I mean
the cool thing about Tetris was is that
I mean or any game thy building block
game is that it actually it speeds up
right and here you really can't control
the speed of the ball which is a little
strange right the other thing yeah I
really do want to be able to swipe down
the balls and Bray done but all the
thing is you just end up getting a whole
bunch of blue balls like these in a row
this distribution you do end up with
this with this kind of unfortunate
situation of the balls that's all the
story each other alright so I'm not
really sure what to do about that now
the game is yet again the goal is to
stack up the ball so they do match this
the kind of a shadow pattern and that's
going to be really hard for me because
I'm gonna actually have to destroy some
blue balls here yeah cuz he's kind of
run out no but you can keep stacking on
the left you can just create a third one
but the goal is to actually make them
match so that's that's that's the
challenge here it so what second I
totally don't understand the goal is to
make them match but you also need to get
them higher yeah I don't think so i
think i think we don't want them the
matter was to not make them it's not
made magic to make the balls match the
shadows right but then you're not
supposed but if you match three of the
same balls and they're gonna destroy
everything right right so that's the key
thing is we want to make the balls match
the shadow but we also don't want to go
above the shadow because if we if we fit
everything into the shitty then we have
to fit all the balls into the shadow oh
ok that's oh so what you're saying is is
if you were to stack it so you've got
two rows right now if you were to stack
it 3i that's no good yes ok and you just
get exactly that tags exactly match the
puzzle there right and because the ball
the roll the ball distribution seems to
be pretty random it can be kind of a
random difficulty I think one of the
challenges with building a game life
threat is getting it difficult to
consistent in two teams that I think
that struggle with with randomness are
this game inward push both right both of
them really get you very different
levels of challenge depending on the
level depending where random numbers you
get so this game actually does have
physics though which is kind of yeah so
you'll see that if there's actually real
physics going on when the balls fall
which sometimes example in sometimes
yeah I think they use box2d so probably
yeah I
they say that idea they said on the
about notes if you look carefully hit up
so did complete the beginner level there
as you see which is cool but also yeah
takes a while so yeah we've now wait
spent buddy I know some things to note
about this this game sort of uses
android things so if you click in the
back key one sweet offense again we just
egg to the game immediately but they're
so and you this game is just again not
not modifying the standard activity
behavior and it does a lot of things in
the same activities a select level is
also done yet kitty hitting the back key
/ quits however they do push up another
activity for when they are doing the
high scores when they're doing the help
so you see that's another equity how
hitting the back he does the right thing
takes you back here to where we were so
this is another another game that's
navigationally challenged and so just
think you know again it just doesn't
make sense if i hit select level it
feels like the back he should bring me
back to / weather and also these sort of
forces me in this case to actually
select something right which is you know
like what do i do if i don't want to
select any what you select the same
thing so again i think from it from an
android perspective it doesn't make
sense putting it okay at the bottom here
the high scores is no necessary it's not
a dialogue ragged look like one too
because or so to show you should too
it's not needed when we just really do
need is the back key not to just quit
out of the damage point so that's all I
wanted to say about stack of all we have
33 kind of three games that we around if
we really did love here start Webster
off with rope rescue rope rescue two are
too
helpful yes a rope rescue and so this is
actually what's this is actually really
cool because if you look at it I mean
even from the splash screen you can
automatically start controlling the
character which i think is a great way
to kind of invite like integrate and all
that but for one thing is you know we've
seen all these games like cut the rope
or all this stuff you're like oh let's
cut something or oh let's try said well
this one's actually really interesting
you basically take rope and you figure
out once we get past the oh no what am I
supposed to do so the object of the game
is you're supposed to take your rope and
free and hook and hook up on all the all
the all the wheels and then and then
unlock your what your baby birds that
have now been captured so and so what's
really cool there's different elements I
mean there's I mean they'll gradually
what's great is that you know they take
you it's a great way of beginning
setting up the levels on it tells you
okay first this is what you need to do
to unlock the bird cage here's some of
the hazards you need to like kind of
watch out for so in this case it's a
knife you know knife cuts rope you don't
want that to happen it's kind of sad so
there's some other stuff too like fire
fire burns everything probably bad for
you etc etc I think the real the really
interesting thing about this game is
that so this they're showing you here
how we can avoid the knife okay you have
to touch every single one of the loops
rack and loop around them like that and
with what's fun about this games it is a
2d game but it's using it as far as the
user's input and control it is but it is
it isn't done in 3d space with 3d birds
and some really nice looking graphics
and they actually get a little bit of
benefit from that to the the backgrounds
look are fuzzy ate a little blurry
because they're a little lower
resolution than this device but the the
actual game looks very very high
resolution in the text track military hi
rose
so do you think it's actually that
they're blurry because of the device or
do you think it's an intentional depth
of field effect I don't think it's
intentional but I think it works very
well for their that's that was my
feeling maybe I could be wrong there but
it felt it felt like like a graphic so
in this case we can there's actually a
shorter path upon when we and so hipster
editing things about this it looks like
we I can't get the shorter path this
right so there's you have to wait oh I
know as we have to wait till they wait
until until they get into the right
place right actually there's actually
her dad right leaves the shortest path
um so again the game is the game is
pretty cool it's honestly there are not
there are a lot of issues with this game
in terms of technical issues I was
really impressed with it you know I was
there yeah great to see game here that
that's pretty much ready to go yeah so
there's one another cool thing about
this game is that if you go back to the
menu and then you can actually see the
bird sanctuary I'm below or right and
you can see all the little birds that
you've actually saved including
hopefully the butterflies the one nice
to have I'd like about this is that this
would be pretty cool as a live wallpaper
just to track your progress um so if
there's any way to do that that's just
kind of nice to have so yeah I think I
think that would actually take this game
over right definitely to have to have a
bird sanctuary as your live wallpaper I
think it'd be really cool you could be
fun to you some more interactions with
words to you know you can see the birds
we do whatever you know but but I think
that but yeah you know overall again
this gave us very well done who back he
doesn't work out the bird sanctuary
though yes unfortunately fortunate but
you can there's a becky in the actual
thing but yeah but you know probably
need those three men screaming back is
generally bad also we see on to be back
here okay so in general you know we
don't on screen back is not something
that android users you know our custom
to using the grass across all their
games and apps that we'd rather have no
on tree
they're not key support like that but
other than that other than of that
screen the back he's really good right
navigation is important all these things
good job guys another game that we
really liked was i blast mochi to before
you get into i blast mochi to you though
folks i just want to take a quick beer
score yes how many of you yeah have you
even gotten past the neck of your beer
daniel not started drinking at least I
guess right what do you think what do
you think what do you think let's see I
know so that's the thing you know when I
host this show i'm drinking all the time
what's different what what makes you
guys so much I don't want to say better
but different I'm a girl oh come on
where is it oh uh I seem to recall that
you are the girl who asked for the beers
in bottles as opposed do you know
porting glasses or something that I like
enjoying my beer come on now so just
just checking just checking what do you
think though seriously yeah yeah yeah
yeah and just smell it just sort of way
to pester I like the smell I like
raspberry right on the nose there's a
little raspberry uh but on the palate
it's like super Bell multi yeah yeah I
was sure I was really happy yeah is a
subtle raspberry flavor but it's but
it's not overpowering yeah it has a lot
to do right yeah I I just had a check
because honestly this has become one of
my favorite beers I really literally
like it buying it today was you know it
was hard to actually share so I want to
see if thinking all right Ian always
comes through at all there you go make
sure that we enjoy our fridays
absolutely you can throw a lot of ways
there yeah the fear is definitely one of
them so said what with and by the way i
I'm sorry while I have the floor I do
want to shout out to our friend Marcus
Eagleton Bauer in Austria hope you're
enjoying an awesome beer yourself sir
he's the one who said I beer glass of
beer and a Friday review what else you
need on a Friday night
and my friend you know it really depends
on how much beer cuz I found so um so
the one thing you'll see here right at
the beginning okay I blast smoky yes so
hey create and share as your function
wow just jd- going back just restart
yeah this is like one of the best
interest means I've seen for a game
besides okay so after the title I mean
unfortunately there's no audio unless
they can hear audio but can't be changed
but the fact that there's God's a lab I
mean you just have to start the game is
pretty amazing so but i love i love i
love the design of her green you know it
feels really good there's not lots of
icons fluttering things everywhere and
you've got three huge functions pray
creative share and and first of all
that's just let me just say that having
a level creator built into your game is
incredible is incredible and there is an
open thing right there's open Fame you
know yes i know thank you for now or
enable i'm gonna i love you alright
that's cool but but the fact that you
can actually go online look at levels
you can actually go and create your own
levels in the game is is really really
awesome functionality ok on down and you
know so this this gives the game you
know just just an enormous long-term
playable at and I actually kind of
wonder whether they used this at all to
build levels actually within the game
because it is pretty highly functional
all the one thing I do wish others
affection it's like gonna like back back
redo whoa anyway I thought the level
creator was really cute absolutely
there's a lot there's really a lot you
can do with it so you good so you know
these are all elements you'll see in the
game but but I because I thought this
was such a beautiful and unique feature
I wanted to go at least come and haul it
out you know really really great can you
play it even though i did sorry this
kind of physics puzzler you can actually
you can actually you know create your
own stuff with and i think you know a
lot of times one at one of the one of
the complaints i decree
about in this generation of computing is
that there isn't enough content creation
these are all right and content
consumption devices but it's great to
see a game that actually allows them a
lot to you people do user-generated so
really nice surprise to like I didn't
even know that's content created existed
until I actually looked at it so exactly
but let's go back to the actual game
like going to it's late so it's an
arcade level kind of like a another
physics-based puzzler but it's actually
pretty cool and so I mean we'll play the
first level but a lot of it is is just
like you have these little things I mean
I'm a sucker for cute puzzler games but
what's really cool is you basically use
bombs and what you're supposed to do is
take the little little creatures and
kind of use the bombs strategically so
that you can put them in this red portal
and and one of things i really like is a
bait they may make use of simple
graphics to for their tutorials there's
no text in the tutorial right really
really easy for the game developer in
terms of actually internationalizing
this game i think i don't think you
don't you surely don't need to get to
know english in order to play this game
right great it's also it's also very
very straightforward right so I mean
really just beautiful job done there
yeah in great job and also on the audio
as well I think for one thing is a lot
of mobile games don't really take
advantage I'm actually really said you
guys can't even hear some the audio for
this game but this game in particular
has some great music great sound effects
and like even just to transitions like
simple transitions as going between
levels and all that stuff you can really
tell that he does put a lot of effort
into this the interface is also really
really welcome and i think you know
again you can so you know you can closer
to make it fly away okay there's a
little bit of english but not a lot
right and and again you can see that at
his level there is controlled by how how
I actually move this this is a really
nice interface
and then once again he's all set so now
we're going to blow these up and boom we
can actually also chain right timing
which gets which gets more important
it's quite farther and farther into the
game so you know the only real technical
feedback I had for this team was that
the game does of actually restart the
music when you win you better pause and
unpause and so if you're in the middle
of the song it's it starts you back over
at the beginning which is a little bit
unfortunate because you don't even
realize that sound is playing at the
beginning of the music because it's very
very good which is very which is nice
and I can see how that would be useful
but it's also something but that was a
little bit jarring when I was actually
in the middle of playing it but you know
that's a really minor issue I mean
honestly that I did not find anything
significantly wrong at this game and
this game is absolutely ready I can
maybe future down yeah maybe ready to be
feature now but I think what's really
cool is like variety gameplay different
uses of bombs and then also different
uses of time to I mean a lot of its I
mean it's definitely very well thought
out the one thing that I do have a
little bit of problems with is that I
think it requires you to three start
every level before you move to the next
world so I mean it's great to add that
challenge the other the other thing here
who's interesting you notice how this
stuff is cut off at the top right so
this is this is uh this is because we're
on hdmi so by if I pull out hdmi or can
we switch to the other view ok Daniel
the other so we'll switch over to the
other view hero pull out hdmi one thing
you can actually see here is that
actually it isn't really cut off yeah
this this means they're actually not
responding and we're getting a little
audio right maybe I'm just turn it yeah
there it is Friday yep there we are
sorry but you see here that it's not cut
off english we're not responding quite
correctly to the street in size changes
that are happening
when the hdmi cable is right and so
that's causing the top of the screen to
get cut off and you can see here that
how many stars i'm currently working on
and how many levels I many points have
gotten across the levels saw the big
male though is my only comment with the
game was they didn't quite handle this
this ratio on this device that's kind of
sad anyway every level at unlocked
phones world that being said the game is
filled with amazing 10 and we really
loved it yep so good job guys and
there's a lot you know there's bombs to
do all sorts of different things there
are bombs that glue bombs where you can
stick them okies you can there's the
slick bombs what else is there just like
you use the bombs to take people off the
glue it's really very clever well done
and if we didn't even I didn't even get
to the second world because it takes me
three stars on every level which I'm not
there i think it's very very cool you
can also apply the balm effects two
characters so one of the cool levels i
think it was the I think it was a
boulder level right if it goes this
level yeah yeah yeah so do you want one
one of the levels you actually saw them
go back to this yeah we're on this view
here 20 levels you actually have to
solve bye-bye actually applying the glue
to the bomb itself center see the bomb
is there right and i'm going to now
apply the glue to the bomb and boom now
it's covered in green covered in blue
and it's sticking up oh no usually pick
up all three but he only picked up one
this time that's okay but I just didn't
have that I didn't happen quite quite
centered well now if you don't have to
be centered right in the middle of it
and but you know from a value as an
example of okay oh wait there it is
there he goes so that can vary lots of
really clever puzzles in this game and
so yes definitely comes up and then on
top of that I mean you know with the
level creation and the shaping its you
know it really just have a lot going I
didn't question I have the devs when are
you comin wit plushies I would totally
buy your plushies ya know again on
screen backe in general week you know we
don't like here you know I'd rather
see that but you know we doesn't eat
isn't everywhere in the game most time
it doesn't have it my only to comment
for the school overall great job thumbs
up running on so those those are the six
that we find look up we do have one
bonus game here bonus round which is
puppies plaything and one of the
problems of puppies playing an idiot
thanks incredibly long time to load and
this is it so bad here at the beginning
of ya and having some sort of animated
progress he's a really really nice thing
to have now I'm sorry I just have to ask
because I looked at this screen is the
name of this company smut works samata
leveque oh yeah yeah yeah okay and
you'll see and are here you know there's
a lot there's lots of stuff here that
are going on at some of this is and I
think the play from middleware and some
of this is actually in the game it takes
a long time by the way for it to
actually get to where I can click on
these things right rename your dog here
and you can see I'm hit really rename on
your screen right now and it took me
forever to get through this the first
time I play this right it's just a lot
of places in which they have to look at
writing and how they're actually
handling this I actually played this on
my on my Nexus and did not play it on
the on the transit very fine but even on
my Nexus of tens there's definitely
super for mistakes sometimes when you
hit back and exit out of the game and
anyone you want to try and resume it
takes like 10 seconds to load all she
eats is the real the real issue is this
okay you hit you hit I hit go to my lawn
right I'm now lock the device i unlock
the device well now of course that work
just fun so you know that's my I hope to
go to the home screen and I'm gonna get
hit
go back into the house and you'll see
that this is what you yeah now you might
think your device's crashed at this
point right and well like what happened
what's going on here is it game actually
going to recover am I ever going to see
the highlights pre never gain now
sometimes it actually does crash right
um sometimes it actually manages to
recover their na Daan it looks like yeah
and it looks like we got I may be a
crash maybe maybe so on this game also i
dove out of the three high engines is
the only one that actually used it does
not use an target SDK level 11 our bug
so we are seeing the Pat ability menus
showing that here unfortunately but we
aren't seeing a zoom control so at least
it's doing it's doing great you know
some of the work right there and now I
think now it's just totally lost its
having a lot of trouble right so yeah in
fact their work there were there there
were there were some comments about
about various problems here we can see
we're going to go into the game you can
see in if he goes after spending all of
this work I really really wanted to see
you know the game the game to do well
until having the clinical itches hold up
games unfortunate mm-hmm and the game is
fun you know it is it is a sliding game
guide done it in 3d and you get the idea
of how these kinds of games to work all
right so that you know it's so that so
the puzzler is that I can choose the
direction that that the dog is going to
go in and go right on up to the ball but
to get all of the phone so in this case
moving across here and it's nice it's
got its got a light source which is fun
you know a lot of themes don't use
dynamic lighting so it's having having
fun with its single dynamic light and
and that's cool in what I really is you
know it really comes down to right now
is polish on the platform right and
getting getting to that next level it
also looks like there may be some issues
with the playful middleware herself and
and again there's also actually some are
key elements to this and I just did this
wrong that's okay that's okay I'm gonna
get a bad score but it's okay we're not
all perfect I know I know I know you see
actually I should have known this
already but but as you can see you know
it is definitely fun it's actually a
very very simple game with very very
complex presentation and a very
and so for what and stars okay you
completed the level is a lot about I've
got all the bones so here's where a
arcade where you i rightly have to time
now this movement so you don't hit the
bat right but other than that this level
is is like pretty much all of the other
bunkers in game
yeah this is the one where like I was
trying to figure out how to get to the
bone it's okay whatever that's all right
I actually see how to do that but all
right let's any case the game is fun and
you know really it's until apology tell
Dom it's very very important those like
you're into the game especially this is
a very high-end device right so you know
you know tyga three devices at a gig of
ram on it if you're going to reload all
of the textures and all of the geometry
and all of the shaders on you know after
after that four paws which you may have
to do any time you really do need to
have some progress indicator him to let
people know that their device hasn't
crashed because of the experience of
exiting the game going back into the
game oh that's that diet works he works
fine from there it's only if you're no I
get to be get swapped out that's drag
the trouble yep so uh honey that that
was that that was this game I was a once
again puppies playing and you know it
was Rosanna was not actually in the top
six but but it looked intriguing yeah
yeah I mean puppies or puppies are great
I recall that I actually made you guys
yeah I think I made you guys review this
I'm like oh dude we should totally look
at this on the strength of the video
alone and it was really because of
puppies puppies yeah I mean I probably
would have maybe would like to seem
kittens but it's okay you know I don't
know what your thing is with kittens
what do you have against puppies and
kittens my kittens oh wait wait wait
we've got the wrong yeah I don't know
what you have against puppies co what
the hell is your problem co I have
nothing against puppies I like kittens
02 yeah whatever okay thanks
such a hater hitter dude cat sir where
it is on the internet man who watches I
mean everyone watches cat videos that's
true I bet I bet there's no kitten Lexus
keep on ice it's a puppy as though look
at him sliding around he's got his legs
on surprise popin this game is that
would just be angry right tissot
probably wouldn't work as well on ice
versus actually kind of evil don't you
think I don't know cats are pretty
independent I don't know yeah I I just
think I snow Mike at woodys be furiously
pissed off yeah no kidding yeah puppies
FTW I could be kittens Oh kittens
kittens Akina looking right all right
and anyways but anyways that's that's
all we have for today right that is it
for today so so we're actually going to
be reviewing next week so we're actually
doing a UH NFL football oh right yeah
specifically NFL football NFL football
that's too bad yes soccer is a much
bigger for precious a football the real
football no fly so I is we are getting
to the start so we do have we do have
the series here of games we actually I'm
probably not going to have quite as many
NFL creo que but again it doesn't it
doesn't have to be a pure football game
it could be a kickstand
you know so example there are games that
are just you know kick a ball through
the field goal could be a field goal
game it could be fantasy football
football manager I mean this is probably
gonna be my week but unfortunately i'm
going to be in packs so no i think
that's wonderful so so who is going to
be at hacks and we are super excited she
is going to be reporting from pax live
she's know about line but by modern you
mean my phone but that's alright wait
I'm sorry is your phone not an android
phone isn't that modern and your host
water technology wouldn't you say that
you're living in the future with your
nexus s co I'm always living and that's
not an extra set but the Galaxy Nexus
Nexus S is like right now last year come
on actually you know what Co we're gonna
give you an even newer phone for pax oh
yeah oh so like you know if any of you
are attending packs next week I
definitely try to find me I'll probably
wandering the indie mega booth or
somewhere around there so if you have a
game to show me be sure to try to find
me I'll definitely give you a couple of
mins look at me introduce yourself what
do you do for google what do i do for
google ah review game besides RV game
yeah i work with i'm game developers to
kind of bring their games to google play
so in all Google platforms and so maybe
a big deal maybe not probably not i'm
not that big of a deal by know is a
really big deal okay yeah for all of
those of you who thought i was a big
deal poor dan was a big deal i think
anyone actually thought now actually no
actually there were some people who
thought you were a big those in the know
knew that you were a big deal you were
the power behind the google play throne
but now Oh as usurped your position as
generally mostly cuz i fulfill a
demographic that's kind of weird and
rare but right what's like obviously
well i'm bringing diversity to the show
now I mean before it was two Caucasian
hey thank you for the fridge for the
word white white okay I was trying to be
politically correct white guy actually
hey old white guys oh yeah oh yeah I
didn't think you were that old oh hell
yeah did you see my my picture in the
you know before we replaced it with that
awesome picture of you I yeah my hair
had like so much gray in it like more
gray than normal Daniel Pham really did
an excellent job okay thank you first
Thanks case so anyways where you are
wrapping up but definitely a so-so
anything again we did say NFL football
not because it has to be licensed by the
NFL but what we're talking about is
America actually I seem to recall that
the the person who said NFL football was
actually rato when we asked how will we
distinguish it from quote-unquote real
football well actually rich guy took a
skosh there hey we did there was someone
severed scored Scotland that Americans
at pigskin you know I don't I just
really hope we do cover real football
games though because I mean that's also
starting like this you mean soccer
soccer what you need in America soccer
but in outside us it is football point
is the next week is the it's this the
NFL season so we're looking for we're
doing that's in the app review too so ya
fantasy football games I um apps for
tracking your favorite team absolute
involve kicking around really any ball
that's not round but more of an oblong
shape even or even tackling games are
fun too many I've live wallpapers that
are truly awesome around the around NFL
football yeah there's really there's a
lot of options out there
also i will say i would know that soccer
is actually a British term just
described to describe what it was how we
got it but then the Brits decided they
didn't like that anymore so all right
soccer is perfectly acceptable it would
came from the UK so therefore therefore
they must they must find it acceptable
right nothing we say in a British accent
must be believed do you know why because
well thats actually I have no idea is
black so why I I you know because
obviously that's what the announcers on
on those two made for TV products are
using sorry that's true that's a really
nice it's really amazing kappa this
nexus 7 you gotta see it right now then
we could do you could use it as a
teacher oh my God look at the
transformer prime all the amazing uses
this device has you see what's your kind
of trance subscription and oh yes you
have a head oh my god suppose doctor who
is up is starting up soon that's right
that's right so all right and so after I
just offended all of the British and
Australian you know the viewers of this
show so I wanted to apologize for my
poor approximation of an of an accent
from British Isles that Mary our first
time Dan is ever apologized I know me
one Korean deployed more than a hundred
times in the past I know that's true but
you started it started it okay now now
we're starting with who started what
that's why is why am I in the middle of
this okay come on oh geez well anyway um
thanks for your time guys um thank you
20 hotel seattle mcpeek definitely same
way man were not meeting eyes by the
minute we started too late also remember
that right we did start late that's true
so yeah so next to next week coming from
pax in Seattle we're going to have Coke
in so definitely find her say hello and
she's going to be doing finding some
awesome stuff for us hopefully hopefully
I'm sure NFL football on both the app
and the game view go to the moderator
page and nominate your favorite stuff
and I think that's pretty with that
enjoy have a great weekend have a good
weekend no and you guys thanks very much
for everybody on the comment stream
especially Gabrielle Martin Marcus and
09 1095 bit all right not really sure
how to pronounce that name okay okay
thanks a lot you guys we really
appreciate it see you next week see ya